I feel like talking about this movie is
just like you're gonna be so all over
the place because this movies all over
the place movie is so old of this place
and I'm already dreading talking about
it because I can hear all the keyboards
angrily clicking but like this this this
movie bummed me out like I'm just gonna
come on say it like and I didn't want to
hate it and I know things about Zack
Snyder so when I went in I was like okay
even if the reviews aren't very good
it'll least be nice to look at it at
least be kind of badass and fun like not
even fun like the first one still kind
of dreary but there's some badass stuff
there and just this movie didn't have
any of that for me you know like I just
remember this right now the movie was
pg-13 for intense sequences violence
whatever throughout I'm like this no
there's like along most of it is
definitely not action yeah this movie
has a similar structure the person where
it's like a lot of drama a lot of kind
of fear and [ __ ] out and then like Oh
tons of action at the end you know like
and there was only like one fight I
thought was really cool yeah and it's
not be fight yeah yeah like walking away
from this movie I enjoyed it there's I
could see how DC fans would enjoy it
because there's a lot of like hey look
at this character this character just
this lead character with that but even
that like when they're teasing that
Justice League
I thought Wonder Woman was good yeah I
thought she was good I thought they
capitalize off of her a little too much
yeah she just kind of tune in even
though she's barely you know like I wish
you didn't have to Wonder Woman her up
you know and then like they tease like
the flash well but then they have that
moment where the like we're just gonna
tease the whole Justice League right now
yeah it was so in the most uninventive
way and just not cool well yeah and this
movie forgets to be its own movie after
a while when they shoehorn what's
basically a trailer for the Justice
League into the mill they put a
post-credits scene in the movie yeah
like and then it gets that point where
you're like this is so slapdash and it's
so poorly written in the way it keeps
track of its storylines and gives motive
patience explains just about anything it
doesn't seem like they cared about this
movie it seems like they cared about a
future movie yeah you know the bottom
line with this film is this a very weak
script
yes script is like like I think about
Ben Affleck in Batman and I'm like you
know what I thought Ben Affleck was
[ __ ] awesome however when you look at
the writing I'm like Ben Affleck
provided a lot more for Batman than with
the writing a little I was a little let
down by Batman and that's exactly why
cuz I watched it was like I really like
Ben Affleck he even you know kind of I
was afraid of
ooh how is he gonna be Bruce versus
Batman I thought he did a good job at
both yeah and the script just doesn't
give him that many great moments like
he's got some charming moments he's got
some cool did almost detective work but
like he's not [ __ ] Batman like you
know it's knife be lost I feel he has
that in there I just feel like the movie
didn't capture that I feel like he did
the Batman character himself cuz like
this script does that to everyone except
Lex Luthor and that's the thing is every
was like mom Jesse Eisenberg like he was
the only guy who had like a really clear
mission I feel like Zack Snyder doesn't
you know like actually love and know
these characters as much as he tries to
let on this movie like I said before it
doesn't motivate any of its characters
and it feels like it feels like a bunch
of different movies all crammed into one
and the problem is with Batman and
Superman specifically is I feel like we
get to know each other we get to know
them as each other's antagonists and not
as a solid protagonist which leads Lex
Luthor is like the only guy with one
single vision to kind of fill the role
of a protagonist and he's the antagonist
it's a [ __ ] mess like honestly this
movie would have been great if it just
did what we wanted it to do which was
Batman Superman up against each other
let's have them you do with the
ideologies you know beliefs the
philosophies all that clashing and
clashing battle scenes and everything
and by the time they actually fight when
you find out the reason for why they're
about to authorize you to to thoughts
run through my brain one they don't need
a fight yeah like it was so evident that
you can hurt octaves that much more it
could have easily been like
on Batman Mike who's trying to tell you
why we don't need to fight yeah cuz then
I'm like why is Superman just engaging
in a fight with this guy the only rules
of this universe are because like the
whole time yeah and that's the thing is
that's eight I didn't go into this
wanting to dislike it and and and the
thing is the reason I it bummed me out
so hard is because all the elements are
there and an idea that could have worked
and if it just focused and and pared
down on some of the excess [ __ ] this
could have been great and I feel like as
fans if you really love these characters
you kind of got to demand a better movie
and this movie is a holy mess like have
fun with it but that script is is ever
you didn't need Lois Lane in this movie
and like so boring and that's the thing
is like nobody likes Jesse Eisenberg
because he's not the textbook Lex Luthor
best last fall yeah it's not his fault
because his his performance was not as
huge Lackey as I was led to believe it
seemed like it fit and he gave like the
most interesting performance out of
anything to the script he's doing what
the script requires you know he's not
like it's not like he's someone and
someone else just could have done
different delivery and it would have
been fine yeah like he's doing what this
group requires he's supposed to be a
little bit more kooky he's the only guy
he's a jolly rancher to another guy you
know I can puts it in his mouth anything
timid ating yeah he is he does seem
angry he does seem cuz everyone's like
oh he's wacky and I was like he seems
like an angry kind of menacing guy with
you know some quirks about him and he's
the only guy who gets to be like really
compelling to me cuz everybody else just
kinds of looks really serious yeah yeah
and it's Jesse Eisenberg and then a few
supporting character like Laurence
Fishburne's cool Laurence Fishburne I
was funny yeah alfred was cool alfred
was great Holly hunters great and
they're not very big characters yeah
yeah and it's and dude like I don't get
it man I like the house the Zack Snyder
like not listen to anything people said
about man you know what's so weird about
this movie that I found really strange
is I was like oh they're acknowledging
the destruction of matter still cool
literally they're taking that into
account and then like the last half hour
I'm like the kinda just can't all that
zack snyder's great at this he's always
like next time like they talk such a
good game about like okay this was all
necessary that we got a plan we're gonna
make it right and then the movie
improves on none of the thing yeah that
make the first one troublesome and it
makes them more troublesome movie out of
that especially because he does not know
how to capture Superman and only the
riders don't I've heard of like Superman
like I tried to cut slack on that first
movie but he's he's a nothing character
in this movie every season looks like
he's trying to figure out what emotions
are and which one to pick and I'm like I
don't give this since he cares about
anything and the fact that like it's to
the point where it's like it's beyond
the fact that Superman is just you know
like Clark Kent puts on glasses and then
no one sees him it's like I when you
watch like the Christopher Reeves
version yeah you can buy it because it's
not just glasses he is like changing his
whole demeanor his body language his
whole personality and then he's totally
different when he's Superman and then on
a technical level it's like this movie
doesn't bother it's it's the 21st
century everyone's pictures ever were
surveillance and everywhere in this day
and age someone would have noticed Clark
Kent and Superman
totally especially the world's greatest
detective
yeah probably would have figured it out
nobody they could have explained that
and they didn't even try and that's the
problem with this movie as so many
things have it and no one tries to
explain what the effects are or why
motives are unclear even even Jesse
Eisenberg like Lex Luthor by the time it
got to the finale and you're like is
unveiling like his ultimate plan and all
that stuff I'm still like why the script
gets lazy enough at one point when bad
there's a moment where like they were
starting to fight Batman scrapped
Superman and he just happened to set his
[ __ ] weird
sonic Raygun thing man holes like that
you put it right here where the only
tool around is like that's a that's a
sloppy script choice right there and
also do you like the Batman and Superman
fighting we get one fight
yeah I get one fight from them it lasts
like five minutes and it's not even that
cool you know slow and sir
everything they're both just look like
they're really heavy like this is
nothing about this movie truly felt
personal like Bruce Wayne is is like
going if there's even a 1% chance I'm
like what why is it anyone taking into
account that Superman still saved the
world like no one's taking that into
account and they just show us scenes
like that like that's why people freaked
out about the destruction in the first
Man of Steel is because they don't
bother to show us otherwise yeah so
we're left to wonder and we're left to
go out people died I wonder what
happened like you know we're like I feel
like Zack Snyder it needs to work with
this riders better on trimming out
scenes and then expanding other scenes
you don't talk about [ __ ] three-hour
cut for this movie and I'm like I don't
but every scene is like smashed a black
dude it's not like and we have all these
dreams one of the worst fights in the
movie is during a dream sequence so
[ __ ] slow and you can tell they're
not hitting you so and then you have a
fight the fight that is in that one so
he punches that dunya like flips and his
head goes to the floor I was like where
was that the whole rest of the movie
because that's a great fight oh yeah
yeah that's the one kind of triumphant
fight in the whole movie yeah so when
they actually fight it's not even
rewarding because the motives for why
they're fighting a they didn't need to
fight that was the probably my most
upset thing about it I was like dude
come on Clark it's already - let's speak
up and just say like three sentences and
I guarantee you Batman will probably
reconsider yeah like you don't have to
oh smart guy he's that's the other thing
is like he's the world's greatest
detective and in this movie he kind of
does all his detective work cuz no one's
paying attention to what he's doing ya
know he's like he's kind of an okay
fighter I guess he's got a lot of cool
[ __ ] and he finds information real easy
the worst part of it that they did with
Batman and I heard about this and I was
like maybe it's not as bad as people
made me out to be but then I ended up
throwing my hands up in the air yeah he
is a [ __ ] killer in this movie even
if they're bad got like hey they make a
point out of that at most the other bad
movies is like he drops them off or at
least you know incapacitate
doesn't kill him this movie he's got
guns so big you're like I don't know
dude I guess you were always out there
for this like like the Dark Knight
trilogy clearly making makes it very
clear Batman doesn't kill you watch the
cartoons the comics that is such an
important detail to Batman and if
they'll if they wanted him to kill in
this movie I would have had liked to
have been seen some justification he's
been put over the edge now and he
doesn't give a [ __ ] and this time he was
like it's just what he does that's the
thing is that's you know me I'm open to
[ __ ] and I get more excited about
superhero movies especially when they
you know try something new and different
that's why I don't feel like this is
nitpicking cuz I'm down for a weird like
a darker Batman or Batman who kills as
long as you offer me an explanation if
I'm just supposed to go I know this guy
doesn't kill now he's doing it yeah I
think you [ __ ] up you know it was cool
right when I liked about the first hour
this movie was I thought they were
actually trying to make scenes and they
were trying to like come up with themes
to talk about you know kind of just gets
Canon doesn't [ __ ] matter then first
trailer were like wow false god like
yeah exact question on this exactly this
is exactly the frayed of because it's
Zack Snyder movie the big ideas went to
the background they talked about it once
every 45 minutes or so someone goes but
Superman right what's the deal yeah it's
okay what's worthy ethics and then no
one really tries to talk about music was
okay
there were times where I'm like that
sounds like the dark I'm like yeah there
were some that when they got long
simmered it was one of the composers
baby in junkie XL who just worked on Mad
Max and there are some yeah there are
some cues around like it's the Dark
Knight again and then there are other
cues where I was like ah you got like
especially when they're like in Lex's
house and it's all like thundering piano
and crazy strings like it's creative
like there's cool moments overall like
we'll talk more about it in the spoiler
review but overall like okay positives
Ben Affleck does a great job with what
he's giving Alfred's good Laurence
Fishburne's good Holly Hunter is good
Lex Luthor I think if you just accept
the fact that that is what this script
wanted
he does a good job um there's one or two
there's like one cool action six endings
yeah and this the thing is like it
finally focuses towards the end and it's
just like a little bit it's a little too
late overall this movie's its
overpopulated it's that it's uneven it's
choppy the editing is you know it's not
as horrible as people made it out to be
for me but I still see why people
complained about it and yeah it's like
this movie learned from nothing
including like spider-man 3 came out a
century ago and we're still adding
another crazy super villain who's kind
of important to the comic book history
in the last half hour of am Lex Luthor
it would have been perfect that's just
the one villain yeah
throwing in doomsday was so unnecessary
and it's because I like ISIL out of
context I was like it isn't kind of cool
I guess yeah I like that whole birthing
thing when he first comes on the scene
you're like cool even if it's not quite
doomsday and that's the thing is like
all this stuff I liked about it was all
the stuff that I get is like kind of
wrong or asynchronous but at least it
was interesting yeah you know I give it
a low five out of five low five out of
five I give it a really enthusiastic 10
out of 10
thanks for the camera thanks Tony big
props to Tony Tony Gil know this footage
is gonna be used